okay I I want to talk about the Hillary
email scandal okay you know about the
obsession with Hillary Clinton's email
and like with Benghazi it turns out that
something even worse happened to the
George W Bush administration and nobody
cared the right-wing pundits flipping
out about Hillary's emails now did not
care right-wing media flipping out about
Hillary Clinton's emails now in the
politicians they did not care because
between 2003 and 2009 the Bush White
House lost 22 million emails now these
were not emails about whether there was
a gift filter fish that has been brought
in and past whatever trade situation was
causing an issue with gefilte fish that
Hillary Clinton once emailed about we're
talking about emails in the run-up to
the Iraq war insane stuff was going on
lies building a case for war based on
non-existent weapons of mass destruction
emails about the firing of US attorneys
for political reasons emails about
really serious stuff like Hillary
Clinton the Bush White House was using a
private email server it was owned by the
Republican National Committee rather
than in Hillary Clinton's house if you
say well it's way worse than Hillary
Clinton's house not really the
Republican National Committee is a
political organization that really
should not be involved in the emails of
actual administration individuals who
were in power and legislating along
those lines and and you can make the
argument that it's actually worse than
an individual having their own server at
home I'm not making that argument but
you actually could make that argument I
would say we have relatively equivalent
situations the Bush administration was
supposed to be storing emails as
required by law they did not do that
when the Bush administration was asked
to comply with a congressional subpoena
they refused and did not provide many of
those emails unclear to me whether it's
because they weren't storing them to
begin with or because they just were
refusing to comply researchers looked at
the data from these 22 million missing
emails and they found a very suspicious
pattern
including periods where there were no
emails at all available from the office
of vice-president Dick Cheney and other
officials Hillary Clinton's email habits
have actually been very open very
transparent and very proactive compared
to what happened in the George W Bush
administration its selective outrage as
always and why did I mention Benghazi
well because we have the exact same
situation with Benghazi the four very
tragic deaths in Benghazi under the
Secretariat I don't even know what to
call it while Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State
have been the focus of countless
investigations millions and millions
maybe at this point tens of millions I'm
not even sure how much money how much
taxpayer money has gone into these
hearings over Hillary Clinton's handling
of the Benghazi issue whereas during the
George W Bush administration we had
effectively thirteen Benghazi's
including at the US Embassy in Baghdad
Iraq the US consulate in Karachi
Pakistan the US Embassy in Damascus
Syria the list goes on no hearings no
allegations that condi rice or : powell
needed to be pulled in to these hearings
because clearly they were complicit in
the murder of Americans none of it
because as usual it's the bogus
bottom-feeding pond-scum ask selective
outrage of the Republican Party as we
know it is this a defense of Hillary
Clinton a Miss handling a handful of
classified emails no it is not a defense
it's an exposition of the total
hypocrisy and double standard that is
applied when it is a Republican rather
than a Democrat who engages in this type
of behavior
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the David Pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm /t DPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing